هو الجنيه المصري الى مستويات قياسيه
جديده في السوق السوداء وذلك رغم خسارته
في العام الماضي نحو 858 من قيمته وسجل
سعر جنيه في تلك السوق نحو 37 جنيها
للدولار الواحد جاء ذلك فيما حضر بعض نواب
البرلمان من ان يصل دولار الى مستويات
قياسيه تتراوح بين 38 جنيها وخمسين جنيها
مقابل الدولار الواحد رغم قيام البنك
المركزي المصري برفع اسعار الفائده بنسبه
اثنين في المئه لدعم الجنيه ومكافحه
التضخم وكشف بنك سوسيتي جنرال الفرنسي ان
سعر الجنيه في العقود الاجله هوى الى 40
جنيها للدولار الواحد كما اعلن بنك جولد
من ساكس ان الطلبه على النقد الاجنبي
يتفاقم في مصر بل وصار يتجاوز المعروض
الامر الذي عزز السوق السوداء
كما تهاوى احتياطي مصر من النقد الاجنبي
الى نحو 34 مليار دولار في شهر مارس
الماضي مقارنه مع اكثر من 45 مليار دولار
في نهايه عام 2019 ياتي ذلك في وقت بدات
فيه دول الخليج وضع شروط اقتصاديه قاسيه
لضخ اموال جديده في مصر وتبدو الحكومه
المصريه عاجزه عن وقف تدهور الجنيه في ظل
تفاقم الازمه الماليه وشح الدولار وزياده
الديون الخارجيه وتهاوي الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه ولم تنجح خطوات البنك المركزي
المصري في تهدئه المخاوف في ظل وضعيه
اقتصاديه صعبه وشديده التعقيد